[Music]
wow 48 minutes in thomas hi it's me
thomas and today is william shatner's
birthday he is 91 years old oh not drunk
my advice to you
is this
and please put it on 107 7. i want to
pee on taylor swift with asparagus pee
do you think he made this video before
after he showed up at nightweight's
challenge oh there you go probably
before
how does it make you feel that thomas
frequently shows up in night wave chat a
lot of autistic people watch night wave
why would that bother me frozen he's at
work right now and i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry just real quick real quick
real quick
who's spoken to thomas on the phone
his mother
i have and me
they will not play terrorism
this time it's not gonna happen
they will only play classic rock and
that's the only station we have here in
the bay area for that
they will definitely not play tara swift
they will not play her 107 seven the
bone
there's another one okay well okay he
said it's the only station maybe yeah
that's the other place taylor bourbon
the urban station won't play it the
urban classic rock and the spanish
station probably won't well it's
california the spanish stations
yes at all plural
nope
and also uh
next year on my birthday week of
disneyland
my mom and i are driving
i thought he was gonna say he was coming
to florida i was gonna say you gotta
take him out to
and i'll wear a swimsuit i'll pay for
your gas
and i'll pay for an escort for the day
so you could go with you can't don't
[ __ ] the esc you can't after time thomas
go first i'll get an escort for the day
seconds i want tara to see me i mean
he's not gonna come he's still coming
let's just go on the back door he's
going to go on the front
no we're not also the mouth is still
available i want to be clear no one is
eiffel towering a prostitute with my
money
unless it's you unless it's me okay
um
yes yes
i don't even want the girl
the [ __ ] kim i just want
no you know i'm making it better so you
have to drive around with a prostitute
hello that'll be good for the carpooling
for uag but listen here's what you do
okay you drive down there i'll pay for
the gas i'll give you money just to take
him to a rub-and-tug an asian
rub-and-tug he's gonna yeah he's gonna
like
he
he's gonna probably hate it i don't
think he is yesterday took me to go get
a massage
the masseuse was an asian lady yes she
touched my penis
it was wonderful yes
however she did not give me a hug my
asparagus people looked white
i asked for a kiss on the cheeks she
said asparagus
i asked for a kiss on the cheek she said
no mouth stuff
no
mouth stuff
i gave her 50. and apparently mouth
stuff was okay
yes yes
mouth stuff costs 50
she put oil on her hand and she touched
my penis
yes it cried yes
but then i couldn't finish because
taylor swift came on the radio
i told the masseuse to switch to 107.7
the bone uh
[Laughter]
i kept requesting that for me to finish
she had to put kelly clarkson on the tv
yes
yes
yeah green lobster in the chat don't
take tommy's there he'll start going all
the time and never say no i'm taking him
i don't care
i'd rather him spend money for this in
scratch-offs yes he should get rid of
the scat scratch off
this wall that's gonna be really extra
if you want the scat package at the
massage place you're gonna pay a cat
package yeah
i also requested for her to wear a kat
von d mask but she wouldn't so no more
scratch offs only
like was it was a grab on
okay yeah yes i scratched a scratcher on
the back of a hole and he probably has
like a huge [ __ ] dick
i'm talking about pessi i mean i mean
one could only dream right i'm talking
about pessy
my point is is that
i'll pay for your gas
there's no i will the show will pay for
your gas
and uh the show i don't is it legal can
you write off a hand job
no it's just a massage and you could you
could state it as entertainment i should
ask my accountant
that's robert craig as the two should
ask
let's see how cool my account is
i really am gonna email oh my god oh
[ __ ] i'm not kidding you can't hold on
here's the question did you get to write
off anything from the strip clubs
entertainment yeah if you have somebody
there and it's for business you actually
can it classifies it hold on you would
have to you would have to stand next to
thomas i don't need to stand next to him
as long as i'm in the lobby and i got it
for him i'm fine
it would count as like a gift listen if
i need to get one for myself i will
right next to him and you guys could
hold hands okay that's fine
uh okay
can i
write off a hand job
your accountant's gonna freaking message
marie scent
and she'll be like answer the [ __ ]
question
um president's sent
i'll let you know
i'll let you know if uh
cheryl's still my accountant
um i have a female accountant
oh guys
is she jewish at least
no
but you're learning a woman oh god your
finances are [ __ ] yeah no wonder i got
audited
because it's good for that
and i also found that pregnant women
cannot go into hot tubs
that's true pregnant women shouldn't go
in the hot tubs is it temperature they
might get twice as pregnant because of
all the common the hot tub
it's true public hot tubs private hot
tubs are fantastic public hot tubs are
just
just
no
not supposed to
or
or the thing like they cannot use the
saunas pregnant women nope
not supposed to it's bad for the baby
or ride roller coasters
no
or do jumping jacks
the song is not safe for pregnant or eat
pizza at certain parts of the pregnancy
because it can induce labor or sushi
candy too she can't eat raw fish yeah
can't smoke cigars apparently either red
wine though nope just a little a little
bit a little bit of red they say if
you're pregnant you could have like one
or two bottles of wine tonight and it's
just
just a little oh i'm sorry florida
medical rules are a little different
than everywhere else i don't think
people know that about florida's a
little different you're allowed to have
a couple bottles of wine if you're
pregnant
i mean yeah they encourage it that's how
you get uh more heads i know
oh that's the pina colada
it's like poke it's like pokemon you
find a pregnant woman and then you like
combine her with two bottles of wine you
get a parrothead that's right yeah
the final evolution is a daytona [ __ ]
really bad daytona has a lot of [ __ ]
though
they also have a buckies
and also
coincidence
[Laughter]
i guess we'll never know never know
i don't i imagined my mom's cat norman
snuggling sierra's belly
norman bates my mom's cat's norman bates
i named him hold on sierra's pregnant
now huh yeah now she's sierra mist
yeah
got in my back
i got a high five for pesky i don't give
a [ __ ]
ah
and if the t if she doesn't go to terms
she'll be sierra miscarriage
that one that would thank you
exactly
that was a penis high five that he gave
pessy he slapped him right in the dick
yes
like very soft i think he did he's
talking about besties
it was very soft
like very soft i think she did like that
yes
a smile our face
let me go thomas
was snuggling sarah's belly
it was
very nice
he did what now no he's not he said
something else was snuggling oh the cat
was snuggling sierra's belly yeah i
think oh that's nice
he's just watching this hoping that it
was going to be him yes um i'm going to
do arby's for lunch today
don't do it thomas you're going to have
a stomach ache royce remember he's
talking about
i have to go to the right arby's we've
had this talk dude i do like
okay there are some i've had i've had a
good rb sandwich before uh oh it's
possible it is going to kick you out of
the house now
dude they and and this is going to stop
you know what i got at arby's crinkle
fries seasoning royce
crinkle fries crinkle fries horsey sorry
we had kink crinkle fries yesterday and
i have to go to [ __ ]
sauce
horsey sauce they have curly fries it's
curly fries did you have them with
horsey sauce hold on
you meant curly fries no i didn't have
them with [ __ ] that's been left outside
in the sun no i have the cur they have
the bouncy fries the spring fries yeah
those are fun those are but dude those
are good they're delicious
you go into one in a non-black never
heard of shut up i'm calling thomas
that's exactly what i'm talking about
royce goes to the black ones
probably at work shut up he's off today
till the 28th
he said he's off
i remember that where you know he's up
uh-huh
it's 8am he might be sleeping in can he
hear us no i don't think so but it might
not pick up doesn't look like it
hello
hey thomas it's royce from day wave how
you doing
oh how you doing good you're doing very
well you're on vacation i heard right
yes and tomorrow's my dental appointment
oh wow what are they doing just the
cleaning
cleaning and the treatment treating and
a treatment oh quick question what
celebrity was born july 14th
i believe um
i'm not sure okay what about july 24th
jennifer lopez and uh linda carter and
he's right and he's right thank you
thomas uh hey man how you enjoying your
vacation what have you done so far
hold on isn't the 24th your birthday
yeah
what have you done so far for your
vacation
i believe um i'm gonna do my recycling
today
nice you're gonna get a little bit of
money you're gonna buy some scratchers
uh on my
on thursdays i always do like on
painting payday
payday payday yeah no that's that's
great did they did they remove the mask
thing that you had to do at work do you
have to wear a mask
on the mask on the bus i have to wear a
mask oh if i go on the plane the floor
and a half too oh yeah yeah are you
coming to florida soon do you know
uh no but next year i'm taking my cousin
samantha nathan breon brindling to
disneyland for my birthday next year
nice that sounds oh man that sounds
really fun what land is in california
land yes what's what's the ride you're
looking most forward to writing
uh the millennium falcon from star wars
it's good i've rode that one out here in
disney world i think you're really gonna
like it
i think i will uh did you get to go to
arby's
yes i did
what did you eat
uh the chicken strips and the curly
fries oh yeah all right cool do you use
the horsey sauce
uh no but the only armies that we have
in the berries and sunnyvale cause they
closed the one in san jose oh yeah
that's true hey you know what have you
been at dickies barbecue lately
uh last year many times but not this
year not this year no no you've been
busy i mean i've been seeing your videos
i've seen you been pretty busy oh can i
say thomas i really liked what you did
for st patrick's day with the asparagus
that was great
yes i did that yeah did it smell real
bad
yes it did all right congratulations i'm
actually really happy to hear that it
smelled
uh real bad um and work how's it going
uh have you got here's a question i have
for you have you gotten any hugs from
any girls recently
uh only
maxine is my co-worker and she's leaving
the company but she's getting here to
eric march 11 next year wow
and what celebrities were born march
11th
uh anton yelchin
and katana
oh and anton yelchin passed away right
uh star trek chekhov yeah he's he passed
away that's right and he's correct march
11th he is correct
man uh uh so man i'm really glad you're
enjoying your vacation what are your
what are your plans today besides your
dental appointment have you been playing
any of the new halo
i'm playing halo 6 but uh i've beaten it
before
it's good it's fun though
i had fun time playing halo 6 so what do
you after the dental appointment what is
like a day of thomas oh i have a
question uh any any any beers tonight
uh only four tall canned beers that's it
four talk you're that's awesome thomas
that's amazing golden road uh from los
angeles and pbr
oh you got a pbr nice
that's that's that's great so
you're hey you're hanging out tonight
hey here's a question i have for you
thomas i don't think i've ever asked you
what's your favorite tv show
uh the new macgyver but it got cancelled
oh no really
last year did oh i'm sorry do you like
the old macgyver
yes i couldn't understand but now i do
understand that the macgyver stuff yeah
he's pretty smart how he put stuff
together
like crafting stuff
yeah exact exactly
exactly so works been going good for you
uh yes it has all right so you haven't
putting any any go backs in the freezer
or anything you've been good no
yeah i'll be right back yeah that's
that's man thomas it's it's it's really
it's really really great to hear you uh
pes you have a question for thomas we
can hear you you're winning the studio
uh i mean i mean i thomas uh are there
any video games you're really looking
forward to coming did you get have you
tried eldon ring by chance
uh no i haven't i think you'd really
like it's tough but it's fun yeah thomas
your quick question do you have any
friends that are jewish
no you want to do now thomas yeah pessy
is he's your friend so now you have one
okay i'm gonna protect me look how
excited he is man thomas we love you can
i tell you you are you are absolutely
one of our one of our favorite youtubers
we we watch your videos all the time
um and you really honestly make us happy
every single day and i will tell you
this thomas we've been we have actively
been tweeting kelly clarkson because we
really want you to go on that show
yeah sometime i will so i get that hug
from her damn right buddy and we're
we're telling uh and everyone just so
you know thomas everyone in the chat
right now is saying how much they love
you and they're saying hi and uh oh
thomas quick question if you had to pick
to get a hug from one of these two
people who would you pick first katy
perry or kelly clarkson
kelly clarkson oh yeah that's right good
choice choice more cushion for the
question are kat von d kelly clarkson or
kat von d
uh the second one will be kat von d but
she moved to indiana oh yeah i don't
want to hug indiana people either
uh okay what's cam when's kat von d's
birthday
march 8th march 8th how old does she
know i wonder
she was born 82 whoa my age okay cool
yes she's getting up there but uh but no
hugs lately for many girls with tattoos
well maxine does have to have tattoos
and also my new sister sierra she has a
lot of tattoos nice that's right sierra
sierra's pregnant right
she's having a boy yeah she's oh wow all
right are you are you excited are you
excited to be an uncle go yes
yeah all right you you're gonna you're
gonna take him out to a water park when
he's old enough right
uh actually it's the other person it's
kaylee here's sister who has a child
named vincent in 2027
i'm going to take him to the water park
on my birthday 24. wow that's amazing
2027 he's going to take a concert oh
really
i've never been there are you coming you
know thomas we would love for you to
come to florida at some point i would
love to take you to uh to a dickies out
here or something i know whenever you
can
oh okay hey uh thomas uh i'm actually
just out visiting royce i live in
california you ever get through like the
central valley valley or anything near
fresno
uh i don't live near fresno no but do
you ever pass through there
uh sometimes i do on road trips uh
what's the last road trip you took
in 2017 to uh montana and idaho
nice my cousin samantha's graduation
wow okay congrat oh nice that is that is
absolutely awesome well well the reason
i was asking is maybe i'll have roy
shoot you my contact information because
i'm in i'm just south of fresno yeah we
could grab a beer we have some fans
thomas some female fans that have been
trying to they've been saying that they
would like to meet you and give you a
hug so i would like to work that out for
you
i have one fan that came to my store her
name's lauren
she's also a subscriber nice and she and
she gave you a hug
she did damn that's awesome hey buddy
that's so great you deserve it man yeah
she's a subscriber was she pretty
yeah she was
okay that's great that's great no i get
it hey sixes need hugs too um
so yeah no no i i i get it um so listen
thomas i know it's your vacation i don't
want to take too much of your time i'm
sure you have you have plenty to do you
got to do your recycling and stuff but
man i really really really appreciate
you being on the show and taking your
time to hang out with us thomas you are
one of our favorite people i hope you
have a fantastic day
thank you all right thomas have a good
day buddy see you bud later
bye
sweet boy he got hugs that was amazing
okay so maybe the best interview ever
dude dude dude i've interviewed somebody
i've interviewed mcafee i've even alex
jones that was my favorite ever hey you
have a jewish friend now okay okay that
was hilarious oh you have a jewish
friend okay we're gonna get you all
sorts of hugs
all right all right
i love them rice has interviewed
jim brewer yes that's true i'm sorry
who did nick foley who jones oh mick
foley oh my god that's right theresa
bill lord oh my god
and the one he loves the most jim
jefferies
but no thomas was my favorite interview
of all time billy west i've interviewed
billy west i've interviewed the voice of
[ __ ] fry
yeah buddy but
he doesn't hug women in string bikini
he's so good at birthdays he's so good
at birthdays hold on was lauren one of
yours
i believe so you think lauren was one
i'm almost popping because i was talking
to somebody that was asking you know
which one because they want to give him
a hug and
that's awesome that's great right
thank you for giving one
danny said thomas target individuals and
gang stop them right
thomas doesn't want to hang out with me
no i was going to buy my beer and get it
because i just did the okay
and by the way when i gank stock thomas
it's with hugs so yeah
to be fair ag uh he also gave the okay
treatment to royce and pessi so
he sold all of us there's something to
do about that i also thought he couldn't
hear us that's why i was like oh i got
to take a piss
i kept forgetting that you said you guys
are in the studio he can't hear you he's
just playing hard to get yes
[Laughter]
i need my thomas hugs dude i i will wear
a string bikini
i don't know if he's gonna like whatever
it takes i don't know if he's gonna like
my balls hanging out of it though
i do have a i do have tattoos on my leg
oh he'd like that maybe we'll get you a
wig
yeah with my beard keep the beard though
you guys are into that
i know all right pessy has a wife wow